I have been asked again and again or am asked
again and again why do not you switch to bio,
where you have so ne beautiful landscape and with.
And yes,
it just fits from the picture and what you have to see of course,
society and also politics are demanding it right now.
People are talking about it.
Figures up to 30 percent bioportion.
Only the reality sometimes looks a little different.
Uh.
At the beginning of 2021,
there was a difference of 15 cents between
organic milk and conventional milk per liter of milk,
and that's pretty much what you put into more organic work.
you can't usepflanzenschutzmittel,
you can't use synthetic fertilizers,
you have to pay significant attention when buying feed materials.
Uh,
like what quantities,
where does that mean?
Simple and poignant.
Less drowned per cow and also less drowned per area.
But it is very topical,
so that the 1 dairies pay even less for
organic milk than for conventional milk.
This has several reasons,
one reason is.
Organic milk is only marketed very regionally,
namely almost only in Germany.
Biomilk plays virtually no role in the global market,
which currently functions like a vacuum cleaner.
This leads to the fact that,
of course,
the conventional milk is much easier to settle.
This effect is further stimulated by the fact that
milk production worldwide is currently not getting behind.
This means that in some cases there are
even regions where less milk is produced,
as in the years before,
due to rising costs in production.
So you can see that it's not that easy.
This decision,
but at the moment very clear,
because if you follow your ideals,
that is quite beautiful.
But at the end of the day,
we only have to earn money once,
and money for our business and also for our families.
Because without moss nothing going on,
as it is so beautifully called.
That's it again your amos from ostfriesland.